foreign
[Music]
briefing for Wednesday October 12th I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
with inflation high and economic
uncertainty On The Rise more customers
are putting big purchases like personal
computers on hold
shipments of PCS fell nearly 20 percent
in the third quarter the fastest Pace in
decades according to research firm
Gartner
that's having a knock-on effect on an
essential part of those devices memory
chips
semiconductor makers including Samsung
and Micron have issued Grim forecasts
lowering their profit estimates
so what does this mean for the broader
chip Market joining us to discuss this
is our semiconductors reporter ASA Fitch
hi ASA thanks for joining me hi thanks
for having me you know when we say
memory chip demand is falling how much
of a dip are we actually talking about
it's a pretty substantial dip the
average price for the type of ram that
goes into flash drives and things like
that has fallen about 28 percent in the
third quarter compared to the prior
quarter computer memory the kind of
memory that helps apps run faster on
your phone or computer that has fallen
by about 15 quarter quarter in the past
quarter so it's been a pretty
substantial drop and a pretty quick drop
you tell us a bit about what the market
and competition is like for memory chips
the market in memory is very volatile it
has a lot of ups and downs you know it's
really tied to Consumer demand more than
even other parts of the Computing
electronics Industry are so if you see
fluctuations in smartphones or in PCS
and things like that memory just tends
to go up and down a lot more it's it's a
more commoditized item electronic item
within that overarching sort of
electronic supply chain so as a result
it's kind of treated at almost like a
commodity and it goes up and down quite
a lot I guess maybe now is a good time
to kind of get into what segment of the
semiconductor Market memory makes up and
if this slowdown is hitting any other
segments of that industry
yeah memory is around 27 of the
overarching semiconductor Industries
estimated revenues this year so it's
pretty substantial amount um The
Slowdown we're seeing is affecting other
parts of the industry though um demand
for all kinds of chips is in Jeopardy
because of consumer sentiment because of
rising interest rates spending power is
being challenged so we're seeing that
kind of broader economic effect
basically trickling into all sorts of
things like PCS like laptops what of the
manufacturers of memory chips said about
this slowdown well manufactured
memberships are generally just you know
they're used to this kind of slowdown
because the memory industry is very
cyclical this one comes at a a difficult
time in that a lot of companies want to
grow their production there are
incentives all over the world for people
to expand their Factory Footprints and
companies like Samsung and Micron who
are some of the major the biggest memory
manufacturers in the world are building
new plants they're growing both of those
companies are making huge investments in
the U.S we're talking the tune of
hundreds of billions of dollars so you
know it's kind of an awkward time for
prices to go down and executives are
saying that they're kind of bracing
they're doing things for the in the
short term like slowing down Capital
spending
um just being more conservative and how
they use their money at the same time
they are continuing to invest for the
long term continuing to think about huge
outlays of capital on on major
expansions of their operations so it's
it's kind of a mixed bag in that sense
too the the short term is bad but the
long term potentially could be quite
good because people see that the demand
is there from all kinds of things from a
Time striving to you know
um newfangled AR VR stuff that's going
to consume more chips and be more memory
I mean so given as you say this is a
volatile segment of the market when do
the big players expect to see this turn
around and I guess in some ways should
they have seen this coming given the
massive spike in demand that happened
during the pandemic for Consumer
Electronics yeah you know a lot of
people have been sort of predicting the
downfall of the trip market for a long
time because it is cyclical and and you
know it was time for a cycle to happen
for it's been time for a long time so
maybe to some extent they should have
seen it coming and some did kind of see
it coming in in that respect but if you
ask analysts they seem to expect that
the market at least for computer memory
will bottom out in the first half of
next year and then you know start to
pick up again but this Market is really
unpredictable and as we were talking
about before it's very susceptible to
the fluctuations and consumer demand and
the overarching macroeconomic picture so
there are a lot of contingencies in
those forecasts it's hard to say whether
the first half of next year really will
be the the bottom or or whether there
could be a longer slump for the industry
okay so you're talking about this slow
down in demand does that mean the chip
shortage that we've been talking about
for you know what seems like yours is
finally over
you know strangely enough it doesn't
there are still a lot of segments of the
chip industry that are in shortage or
that have longer lead times that are
just stretched because there are areas
where chip demand is still very strong
if you look at the automotive industry
for example automakers are still having
trouble getting the chips that they need
other people who make medical devices
and other kinds of gadgets and
electronics still are having problems so
what we're seeing now is that there are
some chips in the not to use a a pun but
there are some chips in the armor of the
of the chip shortage story but it's
still happening because the demand is
affecting certain chips like CPUs and
gpus and sort of higher end Computing uh
the brains of your computers kind of
thing but that kind of fall off in
demand and consumer sentiment we're
seeing isn't affecting sort of older
generation chips and different sort of
commoditized chips that automakers and
other other folks need so it's it's
become a more of a 6 picture whereas
previously it was just a general
shortage and that was affecting
everybody
right ace of fish
a conductors reporter
while joining us thanks a lot
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]